[Musique]
pourquoi m'avoir donné rendez-vous sous
la
pluie petite aux yeux si doux trésor que
j'aime
[Musique]
tout seul comme un
idiot j'attends et je m'ennuie et je me
pose aussi quelques
problèm pourtant on s'est connu par une
claire
nuit le ciel était si doux la mer si
belle
oui mais voilà ce
soir j'ai froid et je
m'ennuie
pourquoi m'avoir donné rendez-vous sous
la
pluie j'ai mes
chaussettes qui font
trempettes j'ai des frissons de la tête
au
talon et dans la brume j'attrape un
rume combien de garçons sont-ils morts
de cette
façon mais pourquoi
mais
pourquoi
[Musique]
n pourquoi m'avoir
donné rendez-vous sous la
pluie petit aux yeux si doux trésor que
j'aime tout seul comme un idiot
j'attends là et je m'ennuie et je me
pose aussi quelques
problème pourtant on s'est connu par une
claire nuit dans tout le casino c'était
la
fête pourquoi m'avoir dit
oui tout en baissant la
tête pourquoi m'avoir donné
rendez-vous
sous
la
pluie
[Musique]
foreign